china no recibirá lecciones ni sermones
de nadie cualquiera que intente oprimir
la de nuevo chocara contra el gran muro
de metal formado por 1400 millones de
chinos lo ha dicho esta mañana che sin
pin en el acto central de las
celebraciones por el centenario del
partido si ha recordado las penalidades
pasadas como el colonialismo europeo o
el imperialismo japonés y ha prometido
que esos tiempos de sufrimiento no
regresarán ha sido un discurso muy
combativo pensado para satisfacer a la
audiencia interna pero que da munición a
los que desconfían del auge pacífico de
china es seguro que del acto de hoy se
recordara más el listado de amenazas que
el de los logros como por ejemplo la
erradicación de la pobreza ha sido un
acto dotado de gran simbolismo con el
discurso pronunciado desde el mismo
lugar en el que mao zedong había
proclamado la república en 1949 y que ha
contado con salvas de cañones con
helicópteros dibujando los guarismos del
100 consumo en el cielo y con cazas de
guerra